hey what's going on
what's going on everybody
I was just gonna say I'm feeling better
uh it's Bill Burr that was a [ __ ]
epic somebody's got to turn that into a
ringtone epic cough that was a minor
cough
you know
if [ __ ] uh that what's that fat guy's
name Roger something or other the guy
who does all the uh not really a
documentary The op-ed pieces disguised
as
the [ __ ] was his name not Roger Ebert it
was Roger and me
Michael Moore Michael Moore if he heard
that cough would want to do an interview
with me
he looks at a mine and then I'll pay him
right and now they moved it to Mexico
and they don't lock their doors in
Canada
um
anyway what's going on how are you
do you have a nice Thanksgiving
um
oh
um I obviously spent Thanksgiving alone
believe it or not I'm on the other side
of this cough
and I'm actually starting to feel good
as long as I don't like you know scream
and yell
I'm now not like coughing like a maniac
but I've been banished
my family doesn't want to see me I've
been in my [ __ ]
room in the garage uh Thanksgiving my
family went somewhere else I dropped
them off they gave me a [ __ ] tray of
food
they all wanted me to stay it was my
decision I'm just being a [ __ ]
[ __ ]
um I got to see you know
everybody that I love for like five
seconds and then they gave me like a
tray
and I went back
to the house
and I watched uh
I watched [ __ ] um
the hell did I watch I watched the
football game
who did I pick I had the Giants getting
10 points that worked out good do you
know what my [ __ ] buddy did to me
today
I got money on the Falcons in the first
half he texts me hey you Falcons your
Falcons bet is looking good it's like
what the [ __ ] are you doing
why don't you just tell me my car is
running great
guess what the Falcons end up [ __ ]
the bed they're right down there on the
[ __ ] goal line I don't even see the
game but I imagine the Commanders
I like how they pick commanders so they
could still have and Chiefs they should
call themselves commanders and Chiefs
you know what I mean just to see if they
get in trouble again
the commanders probably went to a
prevent defense gave the Falcons four
shot at the [ __ ] End Zone and that
they couldn't [ __ ] put it in
they're actually to win the [ __ ] game
because the commanders were nice enough
to miss an extra point and it just
[ __ ] it's just like what would the
Falcons be doing
if they weren't in charge of Their Own
Destiny and then absolutely [ __ ] the
bed like week after week year after
[ __ ] year
so anyway
um
yeah I just been [ __ ] staying home I
haven't done any stand up
I was like not talking
believe it or not oh my wife was
enjoying the hell out of that oh my God
she was laughing she was just coming up
to me and she goes I think you're a
[ __ ] douche she's gonna get in my
face who's cracking me up and then I
would have a coughing fit
and uh she would laugh at me but she was
she's been great making me the hot tea
with the [ __ ] lemon and all of that
[ __ ]
so um I feel like
um
I don't know like another couple of days
and I should be right as rain whatever
the [ __ ] this is It's been a [ __ ]
a two and a half I mean it doesn't help
that I'm out there screaming my act for
an hour and 20 minutes it's probably not
what you want to do when you have a
cough
you know
um but that's what I was doing so anyway
uh
so that was my Thanksgiving and then I
when I was waiting for my family to come
home I went on the Criterion Channel and
they had all this 80s horror
and I watched the first half of a movie
that I've not seen since it came out on
cable like 40 years ago I watched cat
people
[Music]
um
a bunch of great actors in it it's kind
of a slow moving
movie but it's got a great soundtrack
with David Bowie Rose
whatever the [ __ ] the song is something
about cats
um
but uh
yeah that was my Thanksgiving
um Thanksgiving
um so I hope you guys had a good one I
hope you weren't [ __ ] sick like I was
something going on out here uh something
going around man I don't know what it is
but I [ __ ] caught it big time
so I'm on the other side of it
um
and that's it I don't know what else to
tell you I haven't been [ __ ] working
out can't go to the gym but I'm gonna
get back there on Tuesday excited about
that
and uh what else do I got going on oh
I'll tell you what I did watch I watched
I watched the game
the Michigan Wolverines first the Ohio
State Buckeyes
arguably
the biggest rivalry
in uh all of Sports at least in America
I think how far back it goes how much
each side [ __ ] hates each other
and uh Michigan looking to win
back-to-back years for the first time
and I don't know how long
and uh I had a bad feeling going in I
was just like I just feel like Ohio
State's going to get him and I'm
watching in the first half
Michigan couldn't run the ball Ohio
State's defense looked great
um initially and I was like oh this
isn't good you know because they're
running back star running back got hurt
last week
and I was going oh [ __ ] it just felt
like that day and then all of a sudden
they just went to the [ __ ] air
because
um I that was Ohio State's game they're
basically like you're not going to beat
us with the run we're taking away what
you do and we you we're gonna make you
play the game that we play
which is more of an I guess an Airborne
and they throw the ball more I guess I
don't know I didn't watch Iowa State
this year
and evidently Michigan goes to the air
gets a [ __ ] 75-yard touchdown
and then got like a [ __ ] 50-something
yard or 40 something yard touchdown and
a 35-yard touchdown they burned him
three times on Long plays they even went
for it and had to fight I don't know if
they went for it but they had a [ __ ]
running back to a jump pass if he led
the receiver that would have been a
touchdown
um they just [ __ ]
beat him at their own game and then
after the half
you know if they got burned on the third
[ __ ] pass Iowa state had to start
respecting their passing game and then
Michigan went to the run and then that
was it they just took over the game and
just [ __ ]
they just you know uh it's that's a
really different Ohio State team they
played really really uh
undisciplined like that stupid [ __ ]
headbutt out of bounds I did not see
Ohio State teams doing that
you know when Urban Meyer was there and
uh I'm sure Ohio State fans are bitching
about their coach so I feel like he's
got one more year to uh
get those kids to [ __ ] listen to them
because
um they gave Michigan a lot
a lot of a lot of stuff and you know as
much as they got called for a bunch of
past interferences they kind of all were
um I think there was one saw there's
always a soft one or whatever but I was
looking for the makeup call and it never
[ __ ] came Michigan just played
[ __ ] great so congratulations to them
such a great game and then next year's
game will be in the big house I went to
that game in like 1999 or 2000 long
[ __ ] time ago
um and I didn't even understand how big
it was then but uh whenever I see the
highlights of the game I'm so [ __ ]
psyched that I actually got to go
to the game so
um
I don't know 100
000 Ohio State fans went home not
[ __ ] happy
and uh that's why that program's great
because everybody's gonna they're all
gonna [ __ ] hear about it and they're
gonna have to
they're gonna have to fix this thing
um but congratulations to Michigan I'm a
Wolverines fan because I have family out
there and everything so I was you know
it was a really [ __ ]
good game through about two and a half
quarters
as far as kind of going back and forth
and like you know but I really thought
Ohio State in the first half first like
quarter and a half I was like it feels
like that day then all of a sudden I was
like Hey Michigan's kind of hanging
around
I'm like nah they're not gonna take over
this game are they I'm just so used to
like [ __ ]
losing
all of those [ __ ] years those Urban
Myers Jesus Christ
um
hadn't won in Ohio State since the year
2000 so it's a weird rivalry though if
you look up the history of it it's just
like
it never seems to go like back and forth
back and forth it always just seems like
and then Michigan had a great team for
seven years and the house they hadn't
worked for 10 years these guys nine
years so but I feel like this has been
like I'd have to look it up for probably
the longest run
of domination I want to say Michigan's
only won one or two times
prior to last year this whole Century so
it was a bad [ __ ] it's a bad time
um anyway but how about this 10 minutes
in I've only coughed twice
um and I did go to the doctor and I did
finally get some antibiotics
um
so that is that has been good
um
anyway took the kids to go see Santa
Claus today
um
that was a good thing it's funny my son
was excited to see him until he got
close to him and then was he didn't cry
or nothing
but he's just like nah I don't want to
go over there I don't want to go over
there he sees a [ __ ] riot
he's really really funny
like strong like he's really putting
together all the words now we were kind
of walking around the mall like all
right buddy let's go this way he's like
no no this way and I'm like no we're
going this way then he crosses his arm
and he goes
starts walking the same way
um and then his sister when he gets
really mad he has a little bit of a
temper I wonder where he got that from
when he starts flipping out about
something
my daughter just literally falls in the
ground laughing watching him lose his
[ __ ]
and um
of course Nia thinks that's hilarious I
think it's hilarious too but Nia's
laughing at it because she
you know
sees my temper and thinks it's
ridiculous which it is or whatever so
anyway
um
I feel good you know I went up and I uh
pre-flighted the helicopter and
everything so I'm gonna go fly tomorrow
very excited to do that
[ __ ]
Kamala Harris was out here
the whole weekend so where I wanted to
fly was this big [ __ ] TFR which is a
temporary flight restriction you can't
fly over a current vice president or
president or whatever
and you always check those because you
don't want to be the jerk off that flies
in there on your little weekend [ __ ]
Warrior flight the next thing you know
you're getting I wonder what you would
get intercepted with with if you're in a
helicopter you would think they would
send a helicopter up there that's when
you just like oh man they're going to
cut my license in half
so
um but like with all the [ __ ] games
and everything you know the football
games college football games the Rams
game I think the Rams at home this I'm
not sure
um
or USC at least had a game and then
Kamala Harris is just these big red
[ __ ] circles
you know in Disneyland always has one
they somehow slipped that in there so
it's just like
yeah you know what I don't feel good
anyway let's just [ __ ] take the
weekend off but uh tomorrow I'm gonna
have a nice flight maybe take a buddy up
or something like that
um other than that I played a bunch of
drums while I was sick
um
I'm working on uh
I'm working on like freeing myself up
on the drums the way I I worked on that
as a comedian and I didn't know how to
do it and
I've been going to this guy's website JP
bube I think is how you say his last
name
um and he has a couple of [ __ ] a
bunch of courses on uh flow mode as he
calls it and uh he had this one on just
a simple lick just right left kick and
moving that thing around and accents and
all that [ __ ] and all of a sudden all
these rhythms you know playing basically
a three against four I know this is drum
nerd [ __ ] but it's [ __ ] exciting to
me
um so I try to type in my [ __ ]
password here to read some of the
questions
um oh my God this [ __ ] guy
this [ __ ] guy this lunatic
driver I was taking my kids out taking
my daughter out to go get an ice cream
and this [ __ ] lunatic
we're all going like [ __ ] eight miles
an hour and this guy comes up on and
passes us all on the right doing like 30
miles an hour 40 miles an hour
and he gets in the right turning lane
and then Cuts back in
and uh we get up to the next light and
I'm seeing you know the guy in the
[ __ ] passenger seat she has his arm
out like you know the windows open like
four inches and he's got like a [ __ ]
cigarette hanging out
and um
I was just looking I'm like Jesus
[ __ ] Christ don't you realize it's
like they don't they're just kids they
don't get it I'm like this [ __ ] guy
the damage he could have done and I'm
telling you as a parent like I never
knew it because we used to drive like
idiots when I was a kid so I can only
get so [ __ ] mad
it's like you [ __ ] young [ __ ] how
dare you do what the [ __ ] I was doing
when I was your age
um
but like uh
you know it's funny you you turn into a
superhero and your murderous fantasies
where I literally got out walked around
his car punched through his window and
pulled him out of the car
the seat belt just broke this course is
just a fantasy
uh
I beat him to a pulp
he had a [ __ ] Glock in his belt and
then I stuck it in the other guy's
[ __ ] face and I like that's where my
head went
[Laughter]
what really happened I waited till the
light turned green and then I beeped at
him and made a right that's basically
what happened you know
you know
that [ __ ] only works in the [ __ ]
movies
um
but that's another reason not to be
taking testosterone supplements in your
50s I love these [ __ ] guys in my
generation now where they got them all
chasing this testosterone it's like
you're not so this like let nature take
its course
okay nature isn't wrong
and you're not gonna fool nature you're
not going to make nature like your body
oh wait a minute
am I 18 and you're going to live longer
I I think all of that stuff is [ __ ]
insane and I don't understand why in
your 50s you would want to go around
with the testosterone of a [ __ ] 21
year old
it just it doesn't make sense
because now you're going to be in your
head you're going to be [ __ ] Jason
Bourne but you're walking around and
you're in your 50s and you know what if
I was taking that testosterone I would
have got out of the car
thinking I could have punched through
his window and pulled him out I would
have got my [ __ ] kicked out of me
if I can stress anything to young people
there's nothing wrong with being old
there's nothing wrong with the aging
process it's actually
everything is about it is [ __ ]
amazing if you just let it happen I mean
I'm not saying like Let Yourself Go
you know sit in the [ __ ] Sun baking
without you know any sunblock on and
[ __ ] eating a [ __ ]
you know a goddamn lava cake I'm not
saying that obviously take care of
yourself but like uh
these [ __ ] weirdos man
they like Placid faces that's what I
don't know what Lake Placid I was just
pictured as like a pristine Lake like
they just have like that uh
I don't know what it is
shiny face
all these shiny face people with their
big eyes I don't know what the f they're
almost like a new race of people
um
I don't know
I I don't know they're just they're
[ __ ] bizarre people and I I really
look at it like a weakness
like when I see somebody uh
but I'm probably wrong because you know
what I'm I'm really starting to think
you know my whole idea like you know the
way I [ __ ] about the NFL
in the prevent defense and how they
don't kick field goals and all of that
type of [ __ ] you know I was watching
Ohio State and Ohio State was playing
conservatively and they punted the ball
away when I thought they should have
and then Michigan went for a field goal
when I didn't think they should have
they ended up missing the field goal and
I was like oh my God you're only up by
[ __ ] 10 points they're going to go
down or seven points they're going to
score a touchdown here it didn't work
against them I think I was watching the
Lions game there was some game I was
watching a pro game on Thanksgiving
and everything that I was saying
they didn't do
and they ended up scoring and they were
right so
I don't know I guess it's kind of like I
have to accept the fact that uh
you know everybody in the NBA is just
going to be shooting three-pointers
which is I don't know I find it
mind-numbingly boring
um
and then when I go to a game I get livid
with the [ __ ] [ __ ] who sits in
front of me in every single time there's
a three-pointer has to hold up three
fingers put their arm up every single
[ __ ] in the [ __ ] team like takes
like 53 pointers
it's not special they're almost taking
one a minute
I don't understand it like how come when
they take two you don't you don't put
two fingers up just it's just that dumb
[ __ ]
you like when college football teams or
whatever they started doing the thing
where in the fourth quarter they all
just started holding up four fingers
you know what I mean the football
players started doing like the fourth
quarter is ours and then the crowd
started doing it as if they were playing
you know like you ever see like you know
like when a defensive player
you know is is nodding vigorously like
he wants to [ __ ] contact have you
ever seen some stupid [ __ ] idiot guy
in the crowd doing the same thing like
nodding
like like you know
like he's actually down there playing
it's like you're not doing anything
you're just in the crowd
um
I don't know
whatever I'm just getting grumpier every
year
what else bothers your grandpa
um
I'll tell you what bothers me is this
week I just anything with a lot of
points I just took
I won my bet I took the Giants with the
points Falcons [ __ ] didn't do
anything and now the Rams are in the
process of just [ __ ] [ __ ] in the bed
goddamn [ __ ] LA Rams
score come on come on ah 20-3 you
[ __ ] well it's 20 to three I got 15
and a half points
this oh but there's a lot of time left I
just figured they're gonna just take
their foot off the gas and give them a
touchdown and they're just not
oh well
you know what are you gonna do
um
anyway
um I don't know if I mentioned this I
did find it [ __ ] if you just really
want to see
what I'm talking about when I talk about
this phony outrage
um
you know
the New York Times does a piece
on
how gambling has become Sports gambling
has become legal
Okay and like anything if you don't
[ __ ] you know watch yourself it could
ruin your life
so they want to say how [ __ ] bad this
is
so the fact that the big four now
allowed you to gamble
I think at the stadium
in all of those [ __ ] Sports
the New York Times decides that they're
going to write a piece about it
and who do they go after do they go
after the leagues
you know that are now doing this no they
don't they go after a guy who runs a
Sports website
and they make him the bad guy and you
know why that is
you know why that is because they're
they're protecting their [ __ ] money
if they really gave a [ __ ] about the
average person out there falling into
[ __ ] you know
a tremendous amount of debt through
Sports gambling why wouldn't you cut the
head off the snake and come at the NFL
they're not going to do it because I
guarantee you whoever owns the [ __ ]
New York Times
you know is owned by a conglomerate that
owns a bunch of [ __ ] and one of them
makes money off of one of those four
[ __ ] major sports so instead they go
after the individual
or it's just the millionth time they've
gone after this guy trying to [ __ ]
cancel him it's just it's such [ __ ]
[ __ ] they do that [ __ ] all the
goddamn time
um
they go after comedians they don't go
after big Pharmacy and all of that type
of [ __ ] they go after [ __ ] uh an
actor
they'll go after uh I don't know a
[ __ ] um
Trump supporters and [ __ ] like that they
not but they never go after the money
man they don't go after the [ __ ]
money all right shut up Bill okay all
right I'll shut up whatever
um [ __ ] Rams can you score a goddamn
touchdown you [ __ ] idiots
um all right let's go to uh let's read
some of the uh the advertising here for
the week and then I'll get into some of
the questions here
um
oh I didn't mention I've been watching a
couple of French shows I've really been
[ __ ] uh
you know working on my French I have a
tutor now
and uh I'm just gonna do this [ __ ] man I
think it's it's really good for your
brain I've been we're playing drums
playing drums is good for your brain
you know I've been laying off everything
else other than coffee
but the first 10 days of every month if
you haven't been listening I just detox
from everything so now I'm not guilty
that I'm crushing a [ __ ] you know
cappuccino and a double espresso it's
like back in the day when I used to
drink I'd get a beer and a shot like I
literally I do those back to back then I
just drink a bunch of waters or whatever
and I'm fine
and um
you know it's my little thing you know
it's what the [ __ ] I do my wife gives me
a look and just laughs I'm just like
what else do I do I don't smoke cigars
anymore I don't I'm like
I don't [ __ ] with weed
again this is all I got all right I have
a little [ __ ]
my little coffee thing here right so
anyway I've been watching um
two shows uh somebody told me uh oh
Bianca uh Christopher who by the way if
you live over in England she's going to
be doing some shows over there
and if you run any rooms man she's a
great comedian she's looking for some
stage time I believe the beginning of
December uh she told me to watch this
show called The Bureau
um
[ __ ] great great show great acting
great um
it's basically about a guy
who works for the uh French CIA
or whatever he's coming from being
Undercover
and uh
you know he ends up catching feelings
for some woman and that's making him
you know behave in a certain way that
could be a [ __ ] issue that's great
and then I went back to the agency
which at first they were speaking too
quickly but now it's not as bad and I
feel like the agency that they're
younger people so they're kind of
talking the way I would hear French
people talking when I go over there
again the next time but um
I don't know I'm really like
[ __ ] locked in on this [ __ ] man like
I do that that pims are French
uh I write out all the stuff and then I
after I'm done writing it out at the end
of the lesson I put it on my flash cards
I've been working on that now I got a
tutor so who knows man I might be old
Billy bilingual
you know I think it's going to take
about 18 months so
whatever I'm just gonna keep doing it
and see what happens but check out the
bureau that's on Amazon and the agency I
think is on Netflix that might be on
Amazon too I'm not sure all right
okay fight camp
a fitter happier you is worth fighting
for getting stronger is hard work but it
doesn't mean it can't be fun fight Camp
blurs the lines between Fitness and
gaming fight Camp brings the best
workout in the world into your home and
makes it fun explore thousands of
workouts led by expert trainers that
meet you on your time live punch stats
motivate you to push harder and help you
map out your progress knock out
achievements or go go head to head
against other Rivals from across the
country or across the living room learn
the basics and sharpen your skills over
time through tailored paths okay it's
safe Fight Club workouts are led by
trainers with over 90 years of combined
training experience they'll break down
every punch and ensure you use proper
forms so you can learn to box safely
family workouts you can even get the
whole family involved phycamp is one of
the only home workouts that is safe for
kids to do because there are no heavy
weights or spinning wheels it's an
amazing way for them to get their energy
out learn something new and share an
experience with the whole family join
the biggest boxing community in the
world without leaving your home with
fight Camp you can get started with
fight camp for as low as 9 dollars a
month by going to fightcamp.com go to
fightcamp.com to learn more
I mean come on man
boxing is one of the greatest workouts
ever you get in the best shape of your
[ __ ] life you look like a badass and
it's just a workout so you don't got to
get your brains knocked around It's Kind
of Perfect
um
Auto frame uh do you take a million
photos only to let them sit on your
phone or get lost in your file yeah I do
us too what if you could put all of your
photos from random camera roll picks to
the high-res wedding album onto one
gorgeous frame you can with aura frames
talk about the struggle of containing
all your digital content photos well I
don't get how you know you get a new
phone and then the one you took with the
old phone all of a sudden you know a
picture from five years ago looks like
it was 50 years ago
I want somebody to come up with a
[ __ ] app that fixes that
um was that on brand uh simply connect
your aura frame
Aura frame to to Wi-Fi to Wi-Fi and use
the free Aura app to add endless
pictures and videos from anywhere in the
world invite friends and family on the
app and have them comment heart and send
new photos to your frame it's like a
real life social network that brings you
and your loved ones joy every single day
um
Auto frame makes easy meaningful holiday
gifts especially for the hard to shop
folks in your life preload with favorite
photos and even a personalized video
message and no need to wrap because
every box is ready to give right now
listeners can take advantage of aura's
cyber monday sale and get 50 off their
best-selling Carver mat frames just go
to auraframes.com that's auraframes.com
these are aura's lowest prices ever so
get yours now before they sell out and
if you missed this sale there will be
deals through the end of the year terms
and conditions apply
all right Roman do you want a better sex
life if so you're not alone but Roman is
here to help Roman is the digital health
clinic for men addressing a variety of
sexual health needs and offering genuine
medication that helps art achieve and
maintain a strong erection
a strong erection not that one that's
[ __ ] half in the game you know got a
big contract doesn't give a [ __ ] anymore
uh Roman offers discreet wipes that help
you last four times longer in bed in men
with low T
low testosterone getting testosterone
levels back to normal can help increase
your libido Roman offers a testosterone
test which includes lab processing and
if it's appropriate to you treatment for
low testosterone at Roman there are no
waiting rooms and no hassle man it's
just a straightforward digital
experience from the comfort of home if
medication or testing is appropriate
Roman will send it directly right to
your door everything arrives in discrete
packaging with free two-day shipping to
learn more about how you can achieve
your personal sexual health goals goals
go to ro.com co slash bird today to get
20 off your entire first order that's
ro.co Romeo Oscar dot Charlie Oscar
slash Burr t-e-a
uh all right oh no no no dot slash Bird
that's it
he is the [ __ ] name of this
thing it's it's r o dot c-o slash Burr
sorry when it copied and pasted the uh
the first
um subject t
IE
um this is somebody that's gonna give me
[ __ ] about drinking coffee
you guys are so judgmental
um T dear Billy Coffee Queen I'm a t
fanatic
I never got into tea
you know
it's like CBD of coffee
I buy loose leaf tea and steep it in a
steel steeping ball
this [ __ ] Dr Seuss right in I buy a
loose leaf tea and steep it in a steel
steeping Bowl
would you could you in a steeping Steepy
ball I would not could not in a Steepy
steel steeping ball you can get them
cheap anywhere I think you might like
the tea world if you get sick of coffee
all right well that's right I did say I
was sick of it
um and then I took a few weeks off and
then I came back there are a lot of
different types of tea you can order
from around the world and most are
better than store-bought bags
uh not that store-bought tea is bad just
so you can level up a bit from there all
right well I'm interested
coffee and tea is like the difference
between smoke and a cigar and a pipe I
feel
like I feel like uh pipe smokers get all
that
different flavored tobacco and all that
um it seems cool anyway also brewing
your own iced tea is a is great when you
get into flavors and varieties you like
spiced teas are good for the holidays
all right
my wife likes tea
I don't know something about it
just seems really effeminate to drink
tea
um
I don't know maybe I'm not secure enough
in my manhood to start drinking tea do I
got to stick my finger out when I do it
um I'll try all right can you give me
some suggestions
um anyway you need protein
oh I like this [ __ ] person okay here
we go now what am I doing wrong I need
protein how the [ __ ] do you know what I
need
um all right
let's take a swig of water here while I
wait to [ __ ] hear what this person is
you need protein
dear Billy Burr
longtime fan recently started binging
your podcast funny guy love it when
Nia's on you two are hilarious I love it
when Nia's on
she's a busy little so-and-so
um I wish she was on here more um I
heard you talk recently about your
breakfast and getting into shape and
whatnot an espresso and an orange really
yeah really I'm on the [ __ ] road you
[ __ ]
and I'm playing all these [ __ ] middle
of [ __ ] nowhere towns they don't have
healthy food but by all means you
[ __ ] judge me
um do you realize that as a man in his
50s which I am as well that you need at
least 1.6 grams of protein per kilo of
body weight to ensure you maintain
proper muscle density
let me ask you this do you know that
you don't know that you just read that
and now you're puking it back to me
one kilo equals 2.2 pounds so that would
be roughly 0.7 ounces per pound for you
Americans down there I weigh about 185
pounds so I need about 130 grams Max of
protein per day sounds nuts but that's
that even if you hit 70 percent it's
better than most lean meats are great
like chicken fish and turkey oh are
those great how do you know they're
great
what do you even know you don't even
know what the [ __ ] is in what you're
reading neither well maybe you do in
Canada I don't down here sir I live in
the United States of America our food is
[ __ ] poison the FDA was infiltrated
by everyone that it was supposed to be
watching and they just pass it they feed
cows to cows
this [ __ ] man-made salmon sitting in
[ __ ] maggots or whatever the hell I
don't even know what I'm eating and if
you could somehow go online and sift
through all the misinformation about
what the [ __ ] you need and what you
don't need you're a better person than
me all right but I need you brow beating
me the fact that I'm on the [ __ ] road
and I don't go downstairs to a [ __ ]
waffle maker every morning for the
continental breakfast
all right there is something to be said
too about giving your digestive system a
little [ __ ] break
you know I a nice light breakfast you
don't know what I eat the rest of the
day
I eat a lot of salads when I'm out there
I'm doing all right okay
Jesus Christ I'm [ __ ] halfway through
my 50s I'm on my way to my 60s I'm still
not a fat [ __ ] I think I know what I'm
doing
you know but you read a bunch you
literally at 1.6 grams
um
are you a personal trainer anyway you
get exactly zero protein with your
current breakfast and it's the most
important meal of the day said just
about everyone ever
oh Jesus Christ I'm not listening to you
a protein shake for breakfast would do
you well simple and easy how do you know
how do you eat a protein shake oh that
little [ __ ] scoop of chemicals what
what is that what the [ __ ] is that
what is it have you ever looking on the
back and then half of the [ __ ] in GNC I
can't pronounce any of it
I've seen absolutely jacked shredded
people on the internet that are
vegetarians
and they say they get all their protein
out of [ __ ] plants okay
and then you go on the internet and it
says the exact opposite so I don't know
what to think
all I know
is eating a grand slam [ __ ] breakfast
and bacon and all of that [ __ ] you know
I don't know everybody I like I have
friends that ate like that and are dead
now
all right so I I like a nice little
light breakfast you know no sugar no
salt it doesn't get me freaked out
either [ __ ] way
you know
I like the caffeine it's sort of uh uh
you know
it doesn't [ __ ]
make me crave other things and then
around lunch time I have a nice big
salad
with a protein I think I'm all right
you know
I actually you know I'm in really good
shape
okay I mean I haven't worked out the
last three weeks but you know I was up
to like doing like a [ __ ] two and a
half minute plank
at 54 and a half [ __ ] years of age
you find me another 54 year old
the average 54 year old they're not
doing that [ __ ]
all right
[ __ ] sitting here judging my goddamn
breakfast
unbelievable
keep them laughing and eat a chicken
breast for God's sake why don't you look
up what the [ __ ] the chickens down here
they don't have beaks and they pump the
chicken breast full of [ __ ] steroids
they can't even stand up they do face
plants living in their own [ __ ] I mean
that's the average chicken down here
um
I don't know
I like eating veggie I really do if you
can get it organic and that type of
stuff after you're done eating that you
don't feel full you're hungry like two
hours later because your body's able to
digest it easily and you [ __ ] you got
this crazy energy
you know I don't know
like I'm always gonna still eat steak
and that type of stuff but I'll tell you
this if I was like [ __ ] sixty percent
veg uh veg vegan or whatever you know
those [ __ ] people live forever
and uh I don't know
I don't know I don't know but I will
tell you this I appreciate it I know
that that was coming from a good place
but like I'm not going to just take
random nutritional [ __ ]
uh advice like
I don't even know what the what the [ __ ]
you do for a living
do you realize that as a man in his 50s
that you need at least like what it
where did you get that information
what the [ __ ] did all of these [ __ ]
guys now I don't know like that like my
whole generation now
I'm you know I've been doing a bit about
this I see these guys like they're
taking before and after [ __ ] photos
uh uh
of them like having a dad bod and then
they're shredded in their 50s it's like
dude you're on steroids
you're on HGH there's no way to do that
at my age naturally and it's okay
what are you trying I don't understand
what exactly what the [ __ ] are you
trying to do
you know
you're gonna go out there and try to
bang a 25 year old
you know I talked to a 25 year old I
talked to a 30 year old they sound like
a [ __ ] child I don't understand these
people are [ __ ] weirdos man I think
they're [ __ ] weirdos
you know
just [ __ ] eat healthy
keep your [ __ ] shirt on you're old no
one wants to see that
okay go get yourself a [ __ ] sport
coat
and that's your goddamn age
[ __ ] 55 years old trying to look like
a backup dancer in the 80s
um anyway
um night sky ads
hey Billy twinkle dick
oh my God I love that
um hey Billy twinklet uh I've maintained
that looking up
is the only direction that doesn't have
any distractions
uh well that might be out of the card
soon too I saw an article about
speculative business prod to project ads
onto the night sky in certain areas of
the city
are you kidding me
like what what
I'm [ __ ] but like these [ __ ]
chasing of a dollar
that these [ __ ] people do I swear to
God man
at some point there's going to be a
revolution and I think everybody
like every [ __ ] sociopath
money-driven [ __ ] lunatic that works
for a corporation should be dragged out
lined up in front of a mass grave and
just shot and we should just [ __ ]
start over again
like this whole [ __ ] mentality that
this just you can never make enough
money
It's never enough you can never have
enough stuff you know
that whole [ __ ] idea
of just [ __ ] working working work so
you have a bunch of [ __ ] stuff is so
stupid
can you imagine the soulless people that
sat in a [ __ ] room
and came up with that idea
to just project ads now people can't
even enjoy like a [ __ ]
you already can't see the stars because
of the glow of the city and now you're
gonna [ __ ] put ads up there
um
and I'll tell you this nobody wants that
nobody wants that but all of the
politicians are grossly underpaid and
the ad Revenue people are just going to
grease their [ __ ] palms and they'll
say how oh this is going to be great
it'll raise a lot of tax revenue and
they'll just ignore the fact that the
reason we have to keep selling our souls
is because we're all under the thumb of
the [ __ ] Ponzi scheme that is our
[ __ ] economy it's just like and they
just never address it they just keep
playing the [ __ ] game
anyway instead of seeing the naked sky
you'd see an advertisement for Coke
aren't they selling enough Coke who
doesn't like Coke a giant bottle pouring
in the sky it's pretty [ __ ] up
maybe once a year for Christmas or the
fourth otherwise [ __ ] that yeah I
remember when they first started having
TV screens in [ __ ] taxis cabs and
everywhere in New York was like we don't
want this they'll [ __ ] stabbing them
and that [ __ ] they went away and then
they came back like a year later and now
they're just there
there's gas stations out here where
you're pumping gas and they just blast
this [ __ ]
they just attack you with this [ __ ]
advertising
it's just [ __ ]
there's like there's no like peace
um
I'm telling you like they're they're
really gonna they're really [ __ ] with
people
um
people need Solitude they need quiet
they needed time to reflect
and this whole [ __ ] thing at these
corporate lunatics
that they're just gonna barrage
you know you with this advertising and
you're gonna listen to it whether you
[ __ ] like it or not is I don't know
there's gonna be a Breaking Point to
this I hope
um
I mean I find like I can't even go to a
[ __ ] NFL game anymore
like just the the [ __ ]
the just the sheer volume
and it's not even the Corral the crowd
they just got these [ __ ] speakers
and like who is this [ __ ] idiot
asking me if I'm ready every [ __ ]
five seconds
are you ready
[Music]
and then they just they pump crowd noise
in over the crowd's just sitting there
not doing anything
it's [ __ ] bizarre I know I know this
this podcast eventually is just gonna be
me complaining about every [ __ ] thing
that has changed since I was a kid
anyway girl says I should know how to
please her
uh hey Bill been seeing this girl for a
few months now I'll skip to the nuts and
beans of the story during a conversation
about sex not during sex I asked her a
basic question about what she likes
during sex a conversation she in this
initiated I'll add she got annoyed and
said I should know what she likes during
sex I was speechless in the
conversations changed I spent days
thinking about this is she she's out of
her mind right yes
she is out of her mind um I don't think
she's out of her mind she might not be
comfortable
with saying
you know
what she wants
um but that that I find
that is uh females have that thing like
you know when they get mad at you but
they don't you don't even know they're
mad at you
and then they get mad because you don't
notice that they're mad
and it's like why didn't you say
something it's like you know he didn't
notice that I was sitting here with my
[ __ ] you know looking out the window
it's like I thought you were looking out
the window
listen
here's something
you don't have to put up with that [ __ ]
you don't have to get in an argument
with her
okay you don't have to be [ __ ] mean
about it I would just be like
you know I would you know have the
conversation again just just I would
revisit and say listen
you know
I only brought that up oh you brought it
up actually
but like I'm just
interested because I care about you and
I want you to be enjoying having sex
with me
but um
I don't know if you noticed I don't work
at a carnival as a mind reader so I mean
don't say [ __ ] like that you know what I
mean
I don't know how old you guys are
um but like that's
I don't know I'm guessing she's more
uncomfortable about talking about it but
she's just like
but if that's like her attitude in
general that you should just know and
you should like figure it out like
um she's this giant
mystery and fascinating person like I
can tell you that uh personally that
would get old quick for me uh that's not
an adult an adult like communicates
the you know like me you know
how good I am at communicating you know
screaming and yelling and having murder
fantasies
um murderous fantasies I should say
all right deleted all my apps
hey Bill I deleted all the social media
apps off my phone I only use it for
email phone and text it's a different
world bill I still use it for music but
no YouTube that's amazing
um my job doesn't require me to get more
than five or six emails a month so I
don't need to monitor that as well I'm
two months sober I'm sharing this
because you've talked about how addicted
they are have you tried this one of the
trick is to always have a book with you
I've read three books since the start of
October if I go to reach for my phone I
reach for the book it becomes an
addictive Escape well Jesus Christ a
light at the end of the tunnel
that was amazing well if I wasn't in the
business that I'm in uh uh I don't I
wouldn't be on social media
um
I think I would still be on YouTube and
then I'm I'm on every
streaming platform to watch movies I'm
sort of addicted
I like watching
movies about cars or that have cool cars
in them old police cars
and [ __ ] like that and um
you know that's the genre
that I like I like watching movies from
the 1960s and 70s and I just like
looking at the cars
and
you know
the clothes and the music and the style
and all of that [ __ ] that I don't know
why but
that [ __ ] will never get old to me
um
like there's a few things that I follow
of like they'll show [ __ ]
someone will have like video of like the
101 Highway in the 70s and I just look
at all the cars and I try to name all of
them and then I get fascinated too with
the mix of cars
you know
where we try to do that on F is for
family where I was just like okay this
takes place in the early 70s in the
early 70s every car wasn't from the
early 70s because that would mean
everybody had the money to buy a new car
that year that's not how it worked
people drove new cars all the way to
cars like 10 years old
um
people in that were in high school in
the early 70s maybe even drove a car
from the 1950s which wasn't considered a
classic it was just considered a piece
of [ __ ] out of style car
um
which is funny because I follow this
thing on Instagram
that it's like some like old school
muscle cars or something and it's all
like these polaroid pictures
of guys with their modified muscle cars
from the 60s that did them in the 70s
back when they would jack up the back
end and put the Slicks on the back
you know more rubber on the road more
traction or whatever like they would
take him down the drag strip and
everything that they were doing to those
cars was lessening the value of them
um which was hilarious because
to them they would just [ __ ]
cars that were seven and eight years old
now they're like Classics so I find that
like fasting like um
um what's his face uh James Taylor and
uh Dennis Wilson the drummer for The
Beach Boys did a movie called uh
two-lane blacktop or something like that
and what was funny was the they were
going from town to town and how they
were making their money was they were
having drag races with people
in the car that they drove around in I
believe was a 55 Chevy Bel Air
and it was just like primer body
you know everything just pulled out of
it you know it's a race car so they
don't have any extra weight in it did
have a passenger seat or whatever
but like I was looking at that thing
going like these guys are just like
beating the [ __ ] out of that car pulled
out the original engine stuck something
else in there
and if they just left that car all
original and hung on to it for a little
while they could have made way more
money
than they were in that movie you know as
those characters drag race in the car so
I find all of that [ __ ]
like fascinating I like being on like
that part of the internet
but uh I kind of have to be on social
media because of uh the business I'm in
but I think that's great that you're
reading like books and stuff like that
that's why I'm kind of like
you know I've been taking these drum
lessons I'm going to take this these
French lessons too because I'm trying to
combat
because I'm 100 addicted to my phone
and staring at it and like you know I'll
be out with my wife and she'll be like
right no phones in the mail and I just
feel myself like just like not even
thinking and just grabbing from my
[ __ ] phone so
um
I think that's great that you're doing
that and that's something to Aspire to
to be reading more
um there's actually a comedian Todd
Parker that wrote this really [ __ ]
good book
um of course I can't remember the
[ __ ] name of it right now but he's
going to come on the podcast and promote
it but I started reading it I was really
enjoying it when I was on the road
and then I forgot to take it on the road
and I kind of got out of that habit of
like reading so I'm gonna bring it on
this next trip that I have
so when Todd comes on the podcast uh
hilarious comic by the way and he
actually
the first time I ever did stand up
it was a contest at Nick's comedy stop
and he was one of the judges so he saw
me the first time I ever did stand up
um so that's always like a running joke
that he didn't vote for me as the best
one or whatever
um
uh but he's a really just a great guy
and a really talented guy so I'm gonna
you know and it's a fun read so I should
get back into that so I think that's
cool you know I'm doing like that 10-day
detox
from like all like stimulants and
everything like maybe uh
you know
I should monitor
my uh social media use or something like
that I have no idea
I don't know
but Instagram's fun though because I
like looking [ __ ] up like I I'll tell
you the [ __ ] truck I'm in love with
right now
is the Ford F-450 regular cab
you know the dually with the pickup back
end I mean that is just the [ __ ] one of
the sickest [ __ ] trucks
I've ever seen and um
you know
it's getting close my F250 is going to
be here soon man
can't believe it
that's going to be great uh
cruising around that [ __ ] thing
big [ __ ] goofball that I am anyway
that's the podcast let's check in on the
Rams score come on you [ __ ] come on
Chiefs go into the prevent going to the
prevent take [ __ ] take what's his
face there you go there you go Rams
scored a touchdown
Ram scored a touchdown 7 29 left
all right good I don't like that Casey
is still gonna [ __ ] play but I feel
like at the end of the game they're
going to go into a prevent and the Rams
are going to cover
that's what I think let's see what about
my Saints When the Saints Go Marching In
oh when them saints go oh [ __ ] they're
getting killed 13 to nothing
I got them getting nine and a half
my theory this week was any spread north
of eight and a half
like the odds of the other team covering
because they're going to the prevent and
give the other team a touchdown at the
end of the game which still could happen
we shall see I'm one and one at this
point so I need the Saints to cover nine
and a half and I'm getting like 15 or 15
and a half with the [ __ ] rims
so right now they're only down by 10
so that's good right I'm still uh still
up five and a half we'll see all right
that's it everybody
um oh Billy's back
and he's redder than ever uh go [ __ ]
yourselves and I'll check in on you on
Thursday